third album here you are on tour yeah
are you enjoying your time on the road
very much always do always do it's nice
to get to play shows and hear people
singing about your lyrics it's the best
now night edition this is the Alba
that's being celebrated right now got me
curious who sleeps in the most sleeps in
it must be commish oh yeah you get your
eight hours of sleep more than that it's
so 16 hours you sleep I used to see
about 5 p.m.
yeah days what's the one thing you love
being doing when you're on tour
exploring I think that's our best to try
and see the cities were in kids will go
back home when people say our how was
mr. Paulo or Toronto and a lot of the
time we were like well the hotel was
nice and the gig is good but everybody
say anything else so we try and go out
and see oh I went to Blue Jays game and
halo trying to get out and do you like
baseball I do after that's not it was
really really good you actually made it
through the whole game and well we left
before I lose to okay why are they
innings or what I think that's two
innings left okay so that's pretty good
yeah because you're right we'll beat
there yeah surge of people but then we
followed it was on the way home they
lost but when you're on stage do you
guys have a ritual before you go on
stage you guys practice or do you pray
what what what do you do
we've got chin which all your heirs pray
in a couple of times don't we yeah times
but no mainly just the chins we rub our
Chin's together he's got a weird
response it's really weird it's really
weird yeah you rub each other's didn't
you so it's like a full wave like this
yeah everyone's weirded out in this room
yes I'm really waiting how many rubs
dude you did what we do if there's a
headline show yeah we do we rub for as
long as the date so if it's the 28th it
will rub for 28 seconds
28 seconds this is quite intense yeah
that was the instinct before our first
ever show it's just because we didn't
want to do the goose
Goose everyone says duck goose goose
goose goose ever been hiccups on stage
it's been if he burps there's been burps
yeah never audible so be like now you
but any issues ever recently were there
was technical issues yeah like what are
we gonna do now recently there was you
know we have like a big intro like it's
intense as that's going like people have
fallen overs like everything going
everywhere and then like it opens up
with James is playing guitar and then it
just like goes to just guitar guitar
didn't work so there's this massive
intro we're all on stage ready and this
get just goes to silence Charlie what
did you do carried on you gotta carry on
yeah it's funny we laugh at my situation
yeah what what does it feel like to see
your fans out there singing your songs
because your songs are pretty big now
yeah it's pretty cool it's really really
nice it's nice to say that you're
influencing people and you're hopefully
bringing positivity to other people in
some way because where you're going to
music because we left it in songs
influenced us and got us through hard
times if we can be that band and then
songs that's a really humbling feeling
yeah you guys are so active on social
media do you interact with your fans
yeah we try to do it's one of the things
that we've kind of tried to maintain
throughout the whole like past six years
really because a lot of our fans that so
yeah keen on social media so yeah we try
any crazy moments with those hmm you
yeah there's been a couple like there
was a weird thing at the beginning of
the band where we used to like tour
around in a little van uh-huh
and people are like trying jump on the
van whilst the van was moving in line in
the middle of the street and you know it
just stopped doing that no one was when
you were going to the loo and a kid just
was you were having to pay hearing the
little guy just came up next year next
year I know say can I have a picture
I'm done yeah and with this album you
there's a two-part series we're doing
the night edition radio you hit number
one on the UK charts for a week is that
for you cool it's really cool because I
think we were quite apprehensive because
it was a different sound for us so we
were kind of nervous is to have the fans
are gonna receive it but this is like
probably the most proud we've been ever
album that we've written and for this
one the third one after having like two
albums as well the fans are still there
supporting it and I'm pushing it up to
number one so I think it's just a credit
to the support of our fans does it give
you more pressure on did the second part
of it the D little bit yeah but it's
almost like we've done it now no it's
gotta feel relieved about it yeah yeah
it's pretty cool yeah what can people
expect from your next part the day
edition any more summer feeling up the
in comparison to the first half yeah cuz
it's it's the day edition so we're
hoping to reciprocate that with the
songs now so it shouldn't notice a
difference I have a whole respect when
bands and groups actually write their
own music so do you guys write
separately or do you come together we
both write you're both okay yeah yeah
it's different every time so a lot of
the time we'll just have ideas and then
bring them to the table and we'll all
work on them together alright with other
people and usually the people we've just
put well we're in the process of booking
like a a little getaway the four of us
where are those we don't know yet so
we're gonna find like yeah as weird a
house as possible in the middle of like
nowhere in England they got some songs
for a few days because you guys spent so
much time together is there anyone who
has annoying habits I don't think so
really it really would have gone on one
of our nerves a bit more oh yeah you're
a nightmare with the bathwater No
you're really used to share and leave
the bathwater in that's the only thing I
think it bug James on some that's doing
the thing ever since do you hate me do
you bout to collaborate with other
artists no no yes yeah we love it it's
fun it's like you can draw on their vibe
and their season
he's like an amalgamation of all of the
different is there any one particular
Sean it'd be cool yeah we did something
with Sean on our first album son good
yeah yeah yeah but like now seeing how
he's grown away and we've grown as ice I
think coming back together to be quite
cool yeah I understand there was a
moment for you at the V Festival that
you performed there and now yeah circle
for you because actually were there
watching the show and then being on
stage I understand that was the moment
yeah he said those are the moments that
I think it's like a nice bit of
realization is how lucky were and what
we've achieved over the past five years
and especially when you like I went and
watched like bands and I was like I'd
love to do that no one day I'd love to
play that stage and we did it so it's
kind of like yeah well pretty make it
pretty proud of what you've done now the
song right now everyone's listening to
his middle of the night who came up with
the concept of the the video we did
didn't we yeah with the director we kind
of wanted to do something different with
sign language we liked the idea and
mainly because you can you can see the
real emotion in their face as they're
breaking up because they're not speaking
they're just you know you can see the
emotion so that's one of the reasons
another reason you came out the video
right came out in conjunction with Deaf
Awareness Week so it all just kind of
work really really well and largely says
I just think it's a different way of
like conveying the emotion of the song
and seeing the breakdown in in a
different way now do you wake up in the
middle of the night end is your phone
next to you yeah yeah yeah to pick it up
yeah check the time sometimes yeah yeah
yeah wakes you up sometimes yes so and I
Drive
yeah and this is one person you like to
text the most for mom your mom yeah
usually the rock yeah he's my Wayne yeah
I'll go with my little brother yeah yeah
like texting yeah that's good how old is
he 14 14 yeah a youngin now you have a
song coming out on Friday yeah we do
are you excited tell us a little bit
about the song itself yes it's another
collaboration with metamer who we did
all night with and yeah it's it's a very
kind of positive there's a weird fly the
positive light upbeat kind of summer
vibe so yeah looking forward to it
coming out we did the music video in
Norway right earlier well last week and
yeah it's a it's gonna be good fun
hopefully now there's a lot of music out
right now there's Katy Perry there's
Taylor Swift who else is there there's
pink there's I'm sure I'm missing
somebody is there anyone that you're
liking their vibe yes Blount for me
sorry James black okay he has a band we
obviously liked ever you know yeah it's
just she took us on a tour in the UK so
we like Taylor's new song actually I'm
curious about though I think this and a
grower I think people are gonna like be
in the cars and they're gonna start
singing it I think yeah it's a very very
catchy song and I like that she always
challenges herself singing house because
I I didn't listen to her much before and
James always been a fan of her since
like country route so like going from
where she's gone transitioning every
album into a new genre and a new phase I
think it's really interesting now yeah
wish her all the best